again, a hard course,
had a failure rate of about 40 to 41 percent
every semester.
With this blended class late last year,
the failure rate fell to nine percent.
So the results can be extremely, extremely good.
Now before we go too far into this,
I'd like to spend some time discussing
some key ideas.
What are some key ideas
that makes all of this work?
One idea is active learning.
The idea here is, rather than have students
walk into class and watch lectures,
we replace this with what we call lessons.
Lessons are interleaved sequences
of videos and interactive exercises.
So a student might watch a five-, seven-minute video
and follow that with an interactive exercise.
Think of this as the ultimate Socratization of education.
You teach by asking questions.
And this is a form of learning
called active learning,
and really promoted by a very early paper, in 1972,
by Craik and Lockhart,
where they said and discovered
that learning and retention really relates strongly
to the depth of mental processing.
Students learn much better
when they are interacting with the material.
The second idea is self-pacing.
Now, when I went to a lecture hall,
and if you were like me,
by the fifth minute I would lose the professor.
I wasn't all that smart, and I would be scrambling, taking notes,
and then I would lose the lecture for the rest of the hour.
Instead, wouldn't it be nice with online technologies,
we offer videos and interactive engagements to students?
They can hit the pause button.
They can rewind the professor.
Heck, they can even mute the professor.
So this form of self-pacing
can be very helpful to learning.
The third idea that we have is instant feedback.
With instant feedback,
the computer grades exercises.
I mean, how else do you teach 150,000 students?
Your computer is grading all the exercises.
And we've all submitted homeworks,
and your grades come back two weeks later,
you've forgotten all about it.
I don't think I've still received some of my homeworks
from my undergraduate days.
Some are never graded.
So with instant feedback,
students can try to apply answers.
If they get it wrong, they can get instant feedback.
They can try it again and try it again,
and this really becomes much more engaging.
They get the instant feedback,
and this little green check mark that you see here
is becoming somewhat of a cult symbol at edX.
Learners are telling us that they go to bed at night
dreaming of the green check mark.
In fact, one of our learners
who took the circuits course early last year,
he then went on to take a software course
from Berkeley at the end of the year,
and this is what the learner had to say
on our discussion board
when he just started that course
about the green check mark:
"Oh god; have I missed you."
When's the last time you've seen students
posting comments like this about homework?
My colleague Ed Bertschinger,
who heads up the physics department at MIT,
has this to say about instant feedback:
He indicated that instant feedback
turns teaching moments into learning outcomes.
The next big idea is gamification.
You know, all learners engage really well
with interactive videos and so on.
You know, they would sit down and shoot
alien spaceships all day long until they get it.
So we applied these gamification techniques to learning,
and we can build these online laboratories.
How do you teach creativity? How do you teach design?
We can do this through online labs
and use computing power
to build these online labs.
So as this little video shows here,
you can engage students
much like they design with Legos.
So here, the learners are building a circuit
with Lego-like ease.
And this can also be graded by the computer.
Fifth is peer learning.
So here, we use discussion forums and discussions
and Facebook-like interaction
not as a distraction,
but to really help students learn.
Let me tell you a story.
When we did our circuits course
for the 155,000 students,
I didn't sleep for three nights
leading up to the launch of the course.
I told my TAs, okay, 24/7,
we're going to be up
monitoring the forum, answering questions.
They had answered questions for 100 students.
How do you do that for 150,000?
So one night I'm sitting up there, at 2 a.m. at night,
and I think there's this question
from a student from Pakistan,
and he asked a question, and I said,
okay, let me go and type up an answer,
I don't type all that fast,
and I begin typing up the answer,
and before I can finish,
another student from Egypt popped in with an answer,
not quite right, so I'm fixing the answer,
and before I can finish, a student from the U.S.
had popped in with a different answer.
And then I sat back, fascinated.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, the students were
discussing and interacting with each other,
and by 4 a.m. that night, I'm totally fascinated,
having this epiphany,
and by 4 a.m. in the morning,
they had discovered the right answer.
And all I had to do was go and bless it,
"Good answer."
So this is absolutely amazing,
where students are learning from each other,
and they're telling us that they are learning
by teaching.
Now this is all not just in the future.
This is happening today.
So we are applying these blended learning pilots
in a number of universities and high schools around the world,
from Tsinghua in China
to the National University of Mongolia in Mongolia
to Berkeley in California --
all over the world.
And these kinds of technologies really help,
the blended model can really help
revolutionize education.
It can also solve a practical problem of MOOCs,
the business aspect.
We can also license these MOOC courses
to other universities,
and therein lies a revenue model for MOOCs,
where the university that licenses it with the professor
can use these online courses
like the next-generation textbook.
They can use as much or as little as they like,
and it becomes a tool in the teacher's arsenal.
Finally, I would like to have you
dream with me for a little bit.
I would like us to really reimagine education.
We will have to move from lecture halls to e-spaces.
We have to move from books to tablets
like the Aakash in India
or the Raspberry Pi, 20 dollars.
The Aakash is 40 dollars.
We have to move from bricks-and-mortar school buildings
to digital dormitories.
But I think at the end of the day,
I think we will still need one lecture hall
in our universities.
Otherwise, how else do we tell our grandchildren
that your grandparents sat in that room
in neat little rows like cornstalks
and watched this professor at the end
talk about content and, you know,
you didn't even have a rewind button?
Thank you.
(Applause)
Thank you. Thank you. (Applause)